I think this question is difficult you
may remember i am refer to this last
lesson and I said this question is hard
but what makes it hard I'll make it hard
I think what makes it hard is that none
of these are numbers well I mean they
are numbers but we don't know what they
are right so you have to deal with
perennials the whole way through and
when you look at these I don't know how
you feel when you look at those I think
this has all the ingredients of the kind
of question that in like your second
last or last section of the paper you
just look at it and you say mmm think I
might come back to this one later it
just looks intimidating okay but it's
not it really isn't okay I know the
results of really awkward but they all
flow out of a very simple situation okay
so let's begin here's we want to do
first you've got these times that get
introduced to you okay t1 is when you're
at this point in the air that's why I
called this a video target okay so at
this point the time is Taiwan okay so we
want to find what that time is the first
thing okay flowing on from that this
point down here where it lands hits the
horizontal again that's tied to okay so
T equals time to when it hits okay so
how do we get some relationships here
and the thing that makes this point
special and you can see on their diagram
and mind is that it's equally high as it
is horizontally from where you started
ok so that's why I mean they've got a
try to go I think draw it in with its
dimensions but i'm going to call its
coordinates HH ok because will they call
it edge as well so i want to be able to
describe this time in terms of all this
other stuff in the equation see that all
these other bits and pieces ok is that a
minus I think it's a minus isn't it yes
it's a month so how do I begin I didn't
want to give me a first step where might
we start
where you will reject our motion
questions begin you're going to have to
probably resolve the initial velocity I
think and from there you can get all of
your time equation okay so let's do that
show yourself up your little resolution
diagram and then you draw your vector in
their angle projection and so on ok so
it's being projected up you've got you
being that initial speed and then you've
got this angle over here ok so from
there you can read off initial x dot at
initial Y dot right because this is at
time equals zero put that in here ok by
now you're starting to predict these
kinds of things because you've seen them
so many times can you tell me right now
one sec start it's going to be this
right angle triangle that sort of you
cause out forward and in the same way
you'll have you sign alphabet ok so
there's my initial conditions I already
know excuse me I start at the origin
excuse me so now I can for my time
equations ok what do I start with what
what questions to buy begin with before
I can generate all of my time equations
Potter
wow it's early isn't it my brain hasn't
warmed up yet okay horizontal
acceleration right we always start there
and in a projectile motion question how
much horizontal acceleration is there no
good okay so you're going to integrate
once and that's going to give you the
first concert let's do it fully this
time Joey but of course using your
initial conditions you can say that that
close that will be your initial velocity
right and in fact that's going to be
mostly the whole way through okay
integrate one more time to get to
displacement right so you'll get this
guy plus the next constant and because
we're starting at the origin this
constants equal to zero for a good
there's all our horizontal time
equations let's do our vertical ones how
much vertical acceleration is there in
this system it's going to be minus Jean
you can tell because G appears in this
equation here so you don't need of 10 or
nine point eight or something like that
so I'm going to have minus G here
integrate once constant number three ok
what's the initial upward velocity it's
you say theta right so that's going to
be your constant where time is zero so
you're going to get this and integrate
one last time
final constant what's the final closet
it's zero because i started the Argent
wait excellent now I have all of my
equations set up one two three four five
six excellent what do I do with these
things remember what I'm trying to prove
try to get to this how do I get there
what's special about t1 what makes t1 a
particular what happens at t1 the x and
the y values are both the same right
that's what makes time one time one ok
so I'm going to say when T equals T 1
right my horizontal and my vertical
displacement ought to be the same
they're both whatever H's ok so I'm
going to have this so now i can take my
true displacement equations right
instead of having this variable T I now
have this actual time t1 and I can
equate them right so I'll do this let's
see here's my ex equation whoops its
capital that's my ex equation and here's
my Y equation
okay suggestions what should i do
remember where I'm headed what might be
a good way one with the fastest way to
simplify this and get to our result oops
sorry it should be a one we're really
asleep already um I see a common factor
three terms common factor through all of
them i'm going to divide now hold on a
second you we usually say oh it's a bad
idea to divide by the thing you're
trying to solve right when you try to
solve an equation but it's okay here why
why is it okay to divide time one where
is it well it's after some amount of
time right you fly up and then you hit
this point okay the important thing I
want to notice about it is that time one
is not zero right it's not much starting
point so if it's not zero i can divide
through by it that's the first thing and
number 2 i'm not interested in zero as a
solution which is the solution you lose
when you divide through okay so at this
point here to justify the fact that i
can divide through by i need to stay
it's not zero that's that's why you can
do this line because otherwise you're
dividing by zero and you get a
nonsensical result okay now all i need
to do with some fancy rearranging okay i
want to make team on the subject so
let's do that i'll swap these two guys
yeah
said okay they've switched sides and now
you can see I'm pretty much there i know
i can factor out this you and I can / g
on two at the same time which gives me
this for a I'm there good now like I
said it looks in today because because
salt letters right they've even been you
know or put a major letter even they
don't have to but the way we went about
it was no more difficult than solving a
normal question just there are no
numbers they're okay right Halep a look
at part two how would you go about this
we now want to find the time of impact
that's what t two is about okay how
would you go about doing that and in
fact I believe the question says hence
heads it's in terms of time one what
would you do I'll let you make a start
first before i show you how